so a friend of mine and I we went for a
run in Central Park the road runners
organization on the weekends they host
races and it's very common at the end of
the race they'll have a sponsor who will
give away something apples or bagels or
something and on this particular day
when we got to the end of the run there
were some free bagels and they had
picnic tables set up and on one side was
a group of volunteers on the table were
boxes of bagels and on the other side
was a long line of Runners waiting to
get their free Bagel so I said to my
friend let's let's get a bagel and he
looked at me and said ah the line's too
long and I said free bagel and he said I
don't want to wait in line and I was
like free bagel and he says Nah let's
it's too long and that's when I realized
that there's two ways to see the world
some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want I could only see the
bagels he could only see the line and so
I walked up to the line I leaned in
between two people put my hand in the
box and pulled out two Bagels and no one
get mad at me because the rule is you
can go after whatever you want you just
cannot deny anyone else to go after
whatever they want now I had to
sacrifice choice I didn't get to choose
which bagel I got I got whatever I
pulled out but I didn't have to wait in
line so the point is is you don't have
to wait in line you don't have to do it
the way everybody else has done it you
can do it your way you can break the
rules you just can't get in the way of
somebody else getting what they want
that's rule number one
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because in my first
business I struggled to believe in
myself I quit on my business partner and
the thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they
gave me the inspiration to keep going as
well as the strategies of what to do and
quite honestly I still need their
stories and motivation today as well so
today let's live your best believe life
and learn how you can find your passion
with Simon signic enjoy
performing Under Pressure whether it's
me or anybody else is the same you know
I have the same pressures as anyone else
there's time there's performance there's
Financial I mean there are you know
there's deadlines my pressures are not
unique
um the situations may be different or
you know but but everybody has the same
kinds of pressures
um but what I found or what I find
fascinating is the interpretation of the
stimuli if let me let me explain
so I was watching the Olympics this last
summer olympics and I was amazed at how
bad the questions were that the
reporters would ask all the athletes and
almost always they asked the same
question whether they were about to uh
compete or after they competed
were you nervous right and to a t all
the athletes went no
right and what I realized is it's not
that they're not nervous it's the
interpretation of what's happening in
their bodies I mean what happens when
you're nervous right your heart rate
starts to go you're you know you sort of
get a little tense you get a little
sweaty right you have expectation of
what's coming and we interpret that that
is I'm nervous now what's the
interpretation of excited your heart
rate starts to go you become you're
anticipating what's coming right you get
a little sort of like tense it's all the
same thing it's the same stimuli except
these athletes these these Olympic
quality athletes have learned to
interpret the stimuli that the rest of
us would say is nervous as excited they
all say the same thing no I'm not
nervous I'm excited and so I've actually
practiced it just to tell myself when I
start to get nervous that this is
excitement you know and so where when
you I used to speak in front of a large
audience and somebody would say how do
you feel I just say a little nervous now
when somebody says how do you feel I'm
like really excited actually and it it
came from just sort of telling myself no
no this is excitement
and it becomes a little bit automatic
later on but it's kind of a remarkable
thing to deal with pressure by
interpreting what your body is
experiencing as excitement rather than
nerves and it's really kind of effective
it makes you want to rush forwards
rather than pull back and yet it's the
same experience I talked to so many
smart fantastic ambitious idealistic
hard-working kids and they're right out
of college they're in their entry-level
jobs and I'll ask them how is it going
and they'll say
I think I'm gonna quit and I'm like why
they say to me I'm not making an impact
I'm like you know you've been here eight
months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
Millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired I mean it was Mutual
or they're quitting
because they're not making an impact or
they're not finding the thing they're
looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love
a job you find Joy from is not something
you discover it's not like I Found Love
here it is I found a job I love that's
not how it works
both of those things require hard work
you are in love because you work very
hard every single day of your life to
stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
Joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that Joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience
it's as if an entire generation is
standing at the foot of a mountain they
know exactly what they want they can see
the summit what they can't see is the
mountain
this large
immovable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys
the problem is
this entire generation has an
institutionalized sense of impatience
and do they have the patience to go on
the journey to maintain love to feel
fulfilled or do they just quit and on to
the next dump it onto the next ghost and
on to the next in the
18th century
there was something that
spread across Europe and eventually made
its way to America called puerpol fever
also known as the Black Death of
childbed
basically what was happening is women
were giving birth and they would die
within 48 hours after giving birth
this black death of childbirth was the
ravage of Europe and it got worse and
worse and worse over the course of over
a century
in some hospitals
it was as high as 70 percent of women
who gave birth who would die as a result
of giving birth
but this was the Renaissance this was
the time of empirical data and Science
and we had thrown away things like
tradition and mysticism these were men
of science these were doctors and these
doctors and Men of science wanted to
study and try and find the reason
for this black death of child bed and so
they got to work studying and they would
study the corpses of the of the women
who had died and in the morning they
would conduct autopsies and then in the
afternoon they would go and deliver
babies and finish their rounds
and it wasn't until somewhere in the
mid-1800s that Dr Oliver Wendell Holmes
father of Supreme Court Justice Oliver
Wendell Holmes realized
that all of these doctors who are
conducting autopsies in the morning
weren't washing their hands before they
delivered babies in the afternoon
and he pointed it out and said guys
you're the problem
and they ignored him and called him
crazy for 30 years
until finally somebody realized that if
they simply washed their hands
it would go away and that's exactly what
happened when they started sterilizing
their instruments and washing their
hands the black death of childbed
disappeared
my point is the lesson here is sometimes
you're the problem
we've seen this happen all too recently
with our new men of Science and
empirical
studiers and these men of Finance
who are smarter than the rest of us
until the thing collapsed
and they blamed everything else except
themselves
and my point is is take accountability
for your actions you can take all the
credit in the world for the things that
you do right as long as you also take
responsibility for the things you do
wrong it must be a balanced equation you
don't get it one way and not the other
you get to take credit
when you also take accountability also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there I spoke at an education Summit for
Microsoft I also spoke at an education
Summit for Apple
that's education for my at the education
Summit for Microsoft I would say that 70
of the executives spent about 70 percent
of their presentations talking about how
to beat Apple
at the Apple education Summit a hundred
percent of the executives spent a
hundred percent of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach
and how to help students learn
one is playing this way and one is
playing that way
one is playing finite and the other one
is playing infinite get switch one gets
frustrated
so at the end of my talk at Microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
Zune when it was a thing
and let me tell you this thing was
spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology I'd ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular I absolutely loved it it was
easy to use and it was bright and
gorgeous and it didn't work on iTunes
which is a different problem so I
couldn't use it but but it was amazing
and elegant my God it was elegant
so I'm sitting in the back of a taxi
with a very senior Apple executive sort
of employee number 12 kind of guy and
you know I like to stir pots so I turned
him I said you know
Microsoft gave me their new Zoom
and it is so much better than your iPod
Touch
and he turned to me and he said
I have no doubt
Conversation Over
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's worse the goal isn't to
be the best every day the goal isn't to
out to outdo your competition every day
that's a finite construction if I had
said to Microsoft I've got the new iPod
touch and it's so much better than your
Zoom they would have said can we see it
what does it do react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them
infinite players play to be better than
themselves
to wake up every single day and say how
can we make our company a better version
of itself today than it was yesterday
how can we create a product this week
that's better than the product we
created last week we also have to play
the infinite game it's not about being
ranked number one it's not about having
more followers on Twitter than your
friends it's not about outdoing anyone
it's about how to outdo yourself
it's not about selling more books or
getting more Ted views than somebody
else it's about how to make sure that
the work that you're producing is better
than the work you produced before you
are your competition
and that is what ensures you stay in the
game the longest and that is what
ensures you find joy
because the joy comes not from
comparison
but from advancement when are you at
your best I'm at my best when I'm around
people who believe what I believe I know
it seems silly but um
I try very very hard to sort of Stack
the deck you know to put myself in a
position of strength
um so for example you know somebody
asked me just yesterday have you ever
had sort of a bad you know engagement I
was thinking myself I'm like not really
but it's not because I'm some sort of
sort of Genius when I'm saying anything
like that it's because I stack the deck
it's because I want to be there I want
to be around people who want me there in
other words if I'm somebody's 10th
choice and like you know I'll probably
turn it down
um whereas if I'm their first choice
they really want me there and so I'm I'm
more likely to have a good engagement
they're supportive of me I'm supportive
of them and so
um yeah I'm at my best when I when I
stacked the deck when I choose to be in
an environment where my strengths are
are there Nelson Mandela is
a particularly special case study in the
leadership world because he is
universally regarded as a great leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but Nelson Mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he was asked one day
how did you learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father to tribal meetings
and he remembers two things when his
father would meet with other Elders one
they would always sit in a circle
and two
his father was always the last to speak
you will be told your whole life that
you need to learn to listen I would say
that you need to learn to be the last to
speak
I see it in boardrooms every day of the
week even people who consider themselves
good leaders who may actually be decent
leaders will walk into a room and say
here's the problem here's what I think
but I'm interested in your opinion let's
go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things one it gives everybody else
the feeling that they have been heard it
gives everyone else the ability to feel
that they have contributed
and two you get the benefit of hearing
what everybody else has to think before
you render your opinion
the skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself if you agree with
somebody don't nod yes
if you disagree with somebody don't not
know simply sit there take it all in and
the only thing you're allowed to do is
ask questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying
and at the end you will get your turn
it sounds easy it's not
practice being the last to speak that's
what Nelson Mandela did every decision
we make in our lives as individuals or
as organizations is a piece of
communication it's our way of saying
something about who we are and what we
believe this is why authenticity matters
this is why you have to say and do the
things you actually believe because the
things you say and do are symbols of Who
You Are
and we look for those symbols so we can
find people who believe what we believe
our very survival depends on it so if
you're putting out false symbols you
will attract people to those symbols but
you won't be able to form trust with
them this is what Tiger Woods did to us
he lied
he lied he told us what he thought we
wanted to hear and it was great and we
were drawn to it and all of us who kind
of like that idea of the sort of the
good guy we're drawn to it until we
found out it was a lie
he could have been the bad boy of golf
he could have had all the same
endorsements and had a fantastic career
and still been hailed as one of the
great athletes of our day but he didn't
he chose to lie good luck forming trust
again tiger we don't believe you
we don't trust you
the goal of putting something out there
if you say what you believe and you do
what you believe you will attract people
who believe what you believe if you go
to one of your friends and you say to
one of your friends
how would you like me to dress
so that you'll like me better
how would you want me to address you how
do you want me to speak so that you'll
like me more
right your friends are going to look and
be like
what are you talking about you know come
on come on come on what should I wear so
that you'll find me more appealing and
how would you like me to speak to you so
that you'll like me more and your
friends are going to tell you just be
yourself
that's why I like you I don't just be
yourself now think about what we do in
Industry what do we do we do market
research and we go and we ask the
customers what kind of things the way we
what style should we speak to you how
should we decorate ourselves what kind
of things are you drawn to so that we
can do those things so you'll like us
more it's just as ridiculous it's just
as ridiculous organizations should say
and do the things they actually believe
and they will attract people who believe
what they believe or they can choose to
lie and at the slightest hint that they
might be lying cynicism sets in and
people start saying I'm not sure I can
trust these guys because there's not a
lot of consistency in all the things
they say and do which means they can't
have a very strong belief set or they're
lying to me
and we call them into authentic the
entire process of asking other people
who we should be is inauthentic that's
hilarious to me all these positioning
studies we do are inherent we're going
to do a study to find out from people so
we can be more authentic that's
hilarious
say and do what you actually believe and
the symbols you put out there the things
you say and the things you do those red
hats are ways that people can find you
what you have the ability to do
as designers is create those symbols and
allow people to use those things to say
something about who they are work for
companies work for clients work for
people who you believe what they believe
show up and feel a part of something
bigger than yourself
and your part is to put what they
believe into pictures and words and
symbols and Graphics so that other
people can use those things to say
something about who they are people put
Harley-Davidson logos on their body to
say something about who they are
corporate logo
ain't no Procter and gambles tattooed on
anybody's arm
because Harley means something they
stand for something people put that
tattoo on there not to tell you that
they own a motorcycle they put that
tattoo there to tell you something about
themselves
do you ever see anybody with a with a
Mac laptop with a sticker over that
beautiful shining Apple ain't never
gonna happen
well you know who I am
do you ever see anybody with a PC break
out the Windex to clean out their
computer
Mac people
have you ever seen a dirty Mac
doesn't exist
does not exist why because it's who I am
these are symbols we use the companies
that are crystal clear in what they
believe and they're disciplined in how
they do it they're consistent in what
they do and everything they say and
everything they do serves as a symbol of
the set of values and beliefs we use
those symbols to say something about Who
We Are
we surround ourselves with the people
and the products and the brands that say
something about Who We Are
and when we can find the people who
believe what we believe we're weirdly
drawn to them because our very survival
depends on it
we need it
and so the more you can give of yourself
the more you can give of what you
believe the more you can discipline with
discipline say and do and do the things
you actually believe strange things
start to happen what are your thoughts
and what's your approach on finding and
building upon Passions
passion is not an actionable word it's
correct you know that those who do the
things that they're passionate about do
better but it's not helpful advice
um and so the question is where does
passion come from
Um passion is a result passion is an
energy passion is the feeling you have
when you're engaged in something that
you love passion is the feeling you have
that you would probably do this for free
you know and you can't believe somebody
pays you to do it you know
um and I think we mistake that passion
is something we do in our private lives
but it shouldn't be done you know in our
careers for example and I'm a firm
believer that you are who you are and
anybody who says I'm Different at home
than I am at work in one of those two
places you're lying and the goal is to
make everything you do in home and at
work something that you have excitement
to do so how do you find the things that
you're excited to do well it's actually
easier than you think what are the
things that you love to do what are the
things that you would do for free you
know how can you recreate that feeling
and and be paid for it so what are the
things that I do on the weekend right I
love
um I'm very involved in the art world I
love to go to museums and galleries but
I love to go see dance and performances
because I want to see how others are are
interpreting the world so that inspires
me new ideas new thoughts new ways
looking at the world are things that
interest me privately and I seek it out
and pay money for it right so does that
mean I have to have a career in the Arts
no it means I have to have a career
where new ideas are explored where
people are experimenting and trying
things out and I have to explore new
ideas and try things out and I'm just as
excited to go to work every day as I am
to you know go do something on a
Saturday night
um and so the idea of finding your
passion is ironically simple because you
should be doing stuff that you enjoy
sometimes
what is the stuff that you enjoy and
then what is the stuff that you love who
are the people that you love and what
are those what they all have in common
how do you explain when things don't go
as we assume or better how do you
explain when others are able to achieve
things that seem to defy all of the
assumptions
for example
why is Apple so Innovative year after
year after year after year they're more
Innovative than all their competition
and yet they're just a computer company
they're just like everyone else they
have the same access to the same Talent
the same agencies the same Consultants
the same media then why is it that they
seem to have something different
why is it that Martin Luther King led
the Civil Rights Movement
he wasn't the only man who suffered in a
pre-civil rights America and he
certainly wasn't the only great orator
of the day why him
and why is it that the Wright brothers
were able to figure out controlled
powered man flight when there were
certainly other teams who were better
qualified better funded
and they didn't achieve
powered man flight the Wright brothers
beat them to it
there's something else at play here
about three and a half years ago I made
a discovery
and this discovery profoundly changed my
view on how I thought the world worked
and it even profoundly changed the way
in which I operate in it
as it turns out there's a pattern as it
turns out all the great and inspiring
leaders and organizations in the world
whether it's apple or Martin Luther King
or the Wright brothers they all think
act and communicate the exact same way
and it's the complete opposite to
everyone else
all I did was codify it
and it's probably the world's simplest
idea I call it the Golden Circle
[Music]
why how what this little idea explains
why some organizations and some leaders
are able to inspire where others aren't
let me Define the terms really quickly
every single person every single
organization on the planet knows what
they do 100 percent
some know how they do it whether you
call it your differentiating value
proposition or your proprietary process
or your USP but very very few people or
organizations know why they do what they
do and by why I don't mean to make a
profit that's a result it's always a
result by why I mean what's your purpose
what's your cause what's your belief
why does your organization exist
why do you get out of bed in the morning
and why should anyone care
well as a result the way we think the
way we act the way we communicate is
from the outside in it's obvious we go
from the clearest thing to the fuzziest
thing
but the inspired leaders and the Inspire
or inspired organizations regardless of
their size regardless of their industry
all think act and communicate from the
inside out
let me give you an example I use apple
because they're easy to understand and
everybody gets it
if Apple were like everyone else
a marketing message from them might
sound like this
we make great computers
they're beautifully designed simple to
use and user friendly
want to buy one
me and that's how most of us communicate
that's how most marketing is done that's
how most sales have done and that's how
most of us communicate into personally
we say what we do we say how we're
different or how we better and we expect
some sort of behavior a purchase a vote
something like that here's our new law
firm uh we have the best lawyers with
the biggest clients we have you know we
always perform for our clients do
business with us here's our new car it
gets great gas mileage it has you know
leather seats by our car but it's
uninspiring here's how Apple actually
communicates
everything we do we believe in
challenging the status quo we believe in
thinking differently
the way we challenge the status quo is
by making our products beautifully
designed simple to use and user-friendly
we just happen to make great computers
want to buy one
totally different right you're ready to
buy a computer from me all I did was
reverse the order of the information
what it proves to us is that people
don't buy what you do people buy why you
do it people don't buy what you do they
buy why you do it this explains why
every single person in this room is
perfectly comfortable buying a computer
from Apple
but we're also perfectly comfortable
buying an MP3 player from Apple or a
phone from Apple or a DVR from Apple but
as I said before Apple's just a computer
company there's nothing that
distinguishes them structurally for many
of their competitors their competitors
are all equally qualified to make all of
these products in fact they tried a few
years ago Gateway came out with flat
screen TVs they're eminently qualified
to make flat screen TVs they've been
making flat screen monitors for years
nobody bought one
[Music]
Dell came out with MP3 players and pdas
and they make great quality products and
they can make perfectly well designed
products and nobody bought one
in fact talking about it now we can't
even imagine buying an MP3 player from
Dell why would you buy an MP3 player
from a computer company but we do it
every day
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it the goal is not to do
business with anybody with everybody who
needs what you have the goal is to do
business with people who believe what
you believe
here's the best part
none of what I'm telling you is my
opinion
it's all grounded in the tenets of
biology not psychology biology if you
look at a cross-section of the human
brain looking from the top down what you
see is the human brain is actually
broken into three major components that
correlate perfectly with the Golden
Circle our newest brain our Homo Sapien
brain our neocortex
corresponds with the what level the
neocortex is responsible for all of our
rational and analytical thought and
language
the middle two sections make up our
limbic brains and our limbic brains are
responsible for all of our feelings like
trust and loyalty it's also responsible
for all human behavior all decision
making and it has no capacity for
language in other words when we
communicate from the outside in yes
people can understand vast amounts of
complicated information like features
and benefits and facts and figures it
just doesn't drive Behavior
when we communicate from the inside out
we're talking directly to the part of
the brain that controls behavior and
then we allow people to rationalize it
with the tangible things we say and do
this is where gut decisions come from
you know sometimes you can give somebody
all the facts and your figures and you
say I know what all the facts and
details say but it just doesn't feel
right why would we use that verb it
doesn't feel right because the part of
the brain that controls decision making
doesn't control language and the best we
can muster up is I don't know it just
doesn't feel right or sometimes you say
you're leading with your heart or you're
leading with your soul well I hate to
break it to you those aren't other body
parts controlling your behavior it's all
Happening Here In Your limbic brain the
part of the brain that controls decision
making and not language
but if you don't know why you do what
you do and people respond to why you do
what you do then how will anybody how
will you ever get people to to to to
vote for you or buy something from you
or more importantly be loyal
and want to be a part of what it is that
you do again the goal is not just to
sell people who need what you have the
goals to sell to people who believe what
you believe
the goal is not just to hire people who
need a job it's to hire people who
believe what you believe I always say
that you know there's uh if you if you
if you um
hire people just because they can do a
job they'll work for your money but if
you hire people who believe what you
believe they work for you with blood and
sweat and tears and nowhere nowhere else
is there a better example of this than
with the Wright brothers
most people don't know about Samuel
Pierpont Langley and back in the early
20th century the pursuit of powered man
flight was like the.com of the day
everybody was trying it
and Samuel Pierpont Langley had what we
assume to be the recipe for success
I mean even now you ask people why did
your product or why did your company
fail and people always give you the same
permutation of the same three things
under capitalized the wrong people bad
market conditions it's always the same
three things so let's explore that
Samuel Pierpont Langley was given fifty
thousand dollars by the war department
to figure out this flying machine money
was no problem
he held a seat at Harvard and worked at
the Smithsonian and was extremely well
connected he knew all the big minds of
the day he hired the best Minds money
could find and the market conditions
were fantastic the New York Times
followed him around everywhere and
everyone was rooting for Langley
then how come we've never heard of
Samuel Pierpont Langley
a few hundred miles away in Dayton Ohio
Orville and Wilbur Wright they had none
of what we consider to be the recipe for
Success they had no money they paid for
their dream with the proceeds from their
bicycle shop not a single person on the
Wright brothers team had a college
education not even Orville or Wilbur and
the New York Times followed them around
nowhere
the difference was Orville and Wilbur
were driven by a cause by a Purpose By A
belief they believed that if they could
figure out this flying machine
it'll change the course of the world
Samuel Pierpont Langley was different he
wanted to be rich and he wanted to be
famous he was in pursuit of the result
he was in pursuit of the riches
and lo and behold look what happened the
people who believed
in the Wright brothers dream worked with
them with blood and sweat and tears the
others just worked for the paycheck and
they tell stories of how every time the
Wright brothers went out they would have
to take five sets of Parts because
that's how many times they would crash
before they came in for supper
and eventually on
December 17 1903 the Wright brothers
took flight and no one was there to even
experience it we found out about it a
few days later
[Music]
and further proof that Langley was
motivated by the wrong thing
the day the Wright brothers took flight
he quit
he could have said that's an amazing
Discovery guys and I will improve upon
your technology but he didn't he wasn't
first he didn't get rich he didn't get
famous so he quit
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and if you talk about what
you believe you will attract those who
believe what you believe but why is it
important to attract those who believe
what you believe
something called the law of diffusion of
innovation and if you don't know the law
you definitely know the terminology the
first two and a half percent of our
population are our innovators the next
13 and a half percent of our population
are our early adopters
the next 34 are your early majority your
late majority and your laggards
the only reason these people buy touch
tone phones is because you can't buy
rotary phones anymore
we all sit at various places at various
times on the scale but with the law of
diffusion of innovation tells us
is that if you want Mass Market success
or mass-market acceptance of an idea you
cannot have it until you achieve this
Tipping Point between 15 and 18 Market
penetration and then the system tips
and I love asking businesses what's your
conversion on new business and they love
to tell you oh it's about 10 proudly
well you can trip over 10 of the
customers we all have about 10 who just
get it that's how we describe them right
that's like that gut feeling oh they
just get it the problem is how do you
find the ones that just get it before
you're doing business with them versus
the ones who don't get it
so it's this here this little Gap that
you have to close as Jeffrey Moore calls
it crossing the chasm because you see
the early majority will not try
something until someone else
has tried it first
and these guys the innovators and the
early adopters they're comfortable
making those gut decisions they're more
comfortable making those intuitive
decisions that are driven by what they
believe about the world
and not just what product is available
these are the people who stood online
for six hours to buy an iPhone when they
first came out when you could have just
walked into the store the next week and
bought one off the shelf these are the
people who spent forty thousand dollars
on flat screen TVs when they first came
out even though the technology was
substandard
and by the way they didn't do it because
the technology was so great
they did it for themselves
it's because they wanted to be first
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and what you do simply
proves what you believe
in fact people will do the things that
prove what they believe
the reason that person bought the iPhone
on the first in the first six hours or
stood in line for six hours
was because of what they believed about
the world and how they wanted everybody
to see them they were first people don't
buy what you do they buy why you do it
so let me give you a famous example a
famous failure and a famous success of
the law of diffusion of innovation first
the famous failure
it's a commercial example as we said
before a second ago the recipe for
success is money and the right people in
the right marketing conditions right you
should have success then
look at TiVo
from the time TiVo came out about eight
or nine years ago to this current day
they are the single highest quality
product on the market hands down there
is no dispute
they were extremely well funded market
conditions were fantastic I mean we used
TiVo as a verb I TiVo stuff on my piece
of junk Time Warner DVR all the time
[Music]
is a commercial failure
they've never made money
and when they went IPO their stock was
at about 30 or 40 dollars then plummeted
and it's never traded above 10. in fact
I don't think this has even traded above
six except for a couple of little spikes
because you see when TiVo launched their
product they told us all what they had
they said we have a product that pauses
live TV
skips commercials rewinds live TV and
memorizes your viewing habits without
you even asking
and the cynical majority said we don't
believe you we don't need it we don't
like it you're scaring us
what if they had said if you're the kind
of person
who likes to have total control over
every aspect of your life
boy do we have a product for you
it pauses live TV skips commercials
memorizes your viewing habits etc etc
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and what you do simply
serves as the proof of what you believe
now let me give you a successful example
of the law of diffusion of innovation
in the summer of 1963
[Music]
250 000 people showed up on the mall in
Washington to hear Dr King speak
they sent out no invitations
and there was no website to check the
date
how do you do that
well Dr King wasn't the only man in
America who was the who was a great
auditor he wasn't the only man in
America who suffered in a pre-civil
rights America in fact some of his ideas
were bad
but he had a gift
he didn't go around telling people what
needed to change in America you know he
went around and told people what he
believed I believe I believe I believe
he told people and people who believed
what he believed took his cause and they
made it their own and they told people
and some of those people created
structures to get the word out to even
more people
and lo and behold 250
000 people showed up on the right day on
the right time to hear him speak
how many of them showed up for him
zero
they showed up for themselves it's what
they believed about America that got
them to travel on a bus for eight hours
to stand in the sun in Washington for in
the middle of August it's what they
believed and it wasn't about black
versus white 25 of the audience was
white
Dr King believed that there were two
types of laws in this world those that
are made by a higher authority authority
and those that are made by man and not
until all the laws that are made by man
are consistent with the laws that are
made by the higher authority will we
live in a just world
it just so happens that the Civil Rights
Movement was the perfect thing to help
him bring his cause to life
we followed not him not for him but for
ourselves and by the way he gave the I
Have a Dream speech not the I have a
planned speech
listen to politicians now with a
comprehensive 12-point plans they're not
inspiring anybody
because there were leaders and there are
those who lead
ERS hold a position of power or
authority but those who lead Inspire us
whether they're individuals or
organizations we follow those who lead
not because we have to but because we
want to
we follow those who lead not for them
but for ourselves
and it's those who start with why
that have the ability
to inspire those around them or find
others who Inspire them
thank you very much
decision making is a process right the
question is what filters are you using
to make decisions are you making
decisions based on the financial rewards
are you making decisions based on how
easy the work will be I mean I remember
in college you know they would give you
this book where they all the students
would rate the classes and they would
rate things like how easy the class was
and how you know how much they liked the
professor and you know the first year I
picked all my classes based on a
workload and I picked everything a low
workload you know and pretty bored uh
didn't work very hard which was fine but
um nothing was Dynamic and nothing
really excited me and I thank goodness
learned that and so the second year I
picked all my classes by Professor
rating regardless of the workload so
every class I had I had these Dynamic
amazing incredible human beings passing
on their knowledge and you were excited
to work hard for them you know
um and so again what the question is
what are the filters we're using and so
if you're only chasing the mighty dollar
then you will have jobs that'll pay you
a little more than the last but are you
enjoying yourself and I talked to a guy
recently who was he's in bad shape like
he he really hates his life and he's
really depressed and he doesn't know
what to do and so we were going through
all his old jobs you know and I said to
give me a job that you've loved and he
hadn't every single job he's chosen out
of college he picked because of the the
money and it's something offered him
more somewhere else he took it you know
regardless and and and and the amazing
thing is he plateaued because if if
you're only chasing the result if you're
only chasing the thing that makes it
easy right
um then eventually you will get bored or
they'll get bored of you right and you
plateau in other words chasing the
almighty dollar if that's your only
thing it eventually flattens out whereas
if you're chasing the thing that excites
you the human beings to be around the
work that excites you the stuff that you
know you know you you can get passionate
about you know the the irony is is
you'll actually make way way more right
because you're excited and I appreciate
your excitement and they reward your
excitement and you're better at your
work because you want to work harder and
all of that stuff you don't have to
strain to work harder so decision making
is simply a matter of filters you know
and so I've made decisions in my life
that I would rather be happy than right
I'd rather do good than uh than get rich
and and so the decisions I make
um put me in positions where when I
leave any engagement when I leave any
meeting I feel that I've contributed
right
um rare are the times anymore where you
walk away going
just think of the money just think of
the money think of the money you know
um I I because it doesn't feel nice and
and the experience I have I don't enjoy
traveling to them and I don't enjoy
traveling home where I have an amazing
experience I am looking forward to
getting there and I'm excited when I
leave yeah you know so it's just
decision made decision making is just a
matter of what filters you use and if
you're if you're good about keeping
those filters up and clear then then
make your decisions I don't judge
anybody by how uh if they choose to use
different filters
um these are just the filters I choose
to live my life you know not right or
wrong just those are my decisions you
know that's my filter how can you help
the human race
how can you help the human race the
human species progress
I'm not joking either this is something
I think we all have to be aware of at
the end of the day the human animal is a
social animal
and our very survival depends on our
ability to form communities to form
cultures what's a community what's a
culture it's a group of people with a
common set of values and beliefs right
what's a country it's a group of people
with a common set of values and beliefs
what's a company it should be a group of
people with a common set of values and
beliefs when we're surrounded by people
who believe what we believe
something remarkable happens trust
emerges and make no mistake of it trust
is a feeling a distinctly human feeling
you know we we all have friends who are
total scripts and yet we still trust
them right
trust is not a checklist simply doing
everything you say you're going to do
does not does not mean people will
inherently trust you it just means
you're reliable we need trust right we
need trust when we're surrounded by
people who believe what we believe and
trust starts to emerge when we trust
them and they trust us we're more
willing to take risks
we're more willing to experiment which
requires failure
we're more willing to explore and go
somewhere that no one has ever gone
before with the confidence
that if we fail if we trip over if we
turn our backs that those within our
community those who we trust and who
trust us will look after us while we're
gone will pick us up when we fall over
we'll help us when we're hurt our very
survival
depends on it
we're not good at everything we're not
good by ourselves you know if I send you
out to go fight a saber-toothed tiger by
yourself odds are tiger one you zero
it's not going to go very well
but if you go out as a group we're
pretty damn amazing and the reason is is
because we all have our strengths and we
all have our certain weaknesses and the
goal is not to fix your weaknesses the
goal is to amplify your strengths and
surround yourself with the people who
can do what you can't do
but it's not just based on skills and
and application and experience it's
based on what you believe it's based on
what you believe you see simply being
good at something and having somebody
else being good at what you're no good
it does not mean you will trust each
other Trust
the sense of trust comes from the sense
of common values and common beliefs
I can prove it
how many of you are from New York
okay a bunch of you are you friends with
everybody in New York
why not why not but when you go to Los
Angeles and you meet someone from New
York you're like hey I'm from New York
and you're best friends
right and when you go to France you're
there you're on the Paris Metro minding
your own business
and you hear an American accent behind
you and you turn around you say hey
where you from they say Los Angeles
you're like hey I'm from New York and
you're best friends
because when you're surrounded by people
who don't believe what you believe when
you're in a strange environment where
you don't feel comfortable you look for
anyone who may share some of the same
values and beliefs that you have and you
start to form a very real and very
intense bond with them simply because
you know that they have a basic
understanding of how you grew up of the
things that you care about of the life
that you live back home
well the same is true when we go to work
do we want to go to work with people who
understand us who believe what we
believe who have a similar view of the
world that has nothing to do with their
opinions and the differences that we
share that's good that's called
diversity that's called advantages to
problem solving which is we can all look
at the same thing from a different angle
and come up with Solutions what I'm
talking about is why should you help
each other in the first place what are
you in pursuit of
now the question is is what creates that
sense of values and beliefs what creates
that sense of trust
right our very human instinct we know
how to find people who believe what we
believe our our survival depends on it
we're biologically gifted with this idea
if I ask you to go out in the street and
find all the people who believe what you
believe you know exactly what to do
you're going to strike up conversations
you're going to start talking to people
and either you'll have a good feeling
about them or you won't either you'll
have chemistry whatever that means
or you don't sometimes it's quick
sometimes it's slow but we know how to
do it it's called making friends it's
called dating it's called networking we
have the innate ability to do it true
story
there was a former under Secretary of
Defense who's invited to give a speech
at a large conference about a thousand
people
and he was standing on the stage with
his cup of coffee and a styrofoam cup
giving his prepared remarks with his
PowerPoint behind him
and he took a sip of his coffee and he
smiled and he looked down at the coffee
and then he went off script
and he said you know last year I spoke
at this exact same conference
last year I was still the under
secretary
and when I spoke here last year they
flew me here business class and when I
arrived at the airport there was
somebody waiting for me to take me to my
hotel
and they took me to my hotel and they
had already checked me in and they just
took me up to my room and the next
morning I came downstairs and there was
someone waiting in the lobby to greet me
and they drove me to this here same
venue they took me through the back
entrance and took me into the green room
and handed me a cup of coffee in a
beautiful ceramic cup
he says I'm no longer the under
secretary
I flew here coach I took a taxi to my
hotel and I checked myself in
when I came down the lobby this morning
I took another taxi to this venue I came
in the front door and found my way
backstage and when I asked someone do
you have any coffee he pointed to the
coffee machine in the corner and I
poured myself a cup of coffee into this
here Styrofoam cup
he says the lesson is the ceramic cup
was never meant for me it was meant for
the position I held
I deserve a styrofoam cup
remember this as you gain Fame as you
gain Fortune as you gain position and
seniority people will treat you better
they will hold doors open for you they
will get you a cup of tea and coffee
without you even asking they will call
you sir and ma'am and they will give you
stuff
none of that stuff is meant for you
that stuff is meant for the position you
hold it is meant for the level that you
have achieved of leader or success or
whatever you want to call it but you
will always deserve a styrofoam cup
remember that
remember that lesson of humility and
gratitude you can accept all the free
stuff you can accept all the perks at
absolutely you can enjoy them but just
be grateful for them and know that
they're not for you
I remember getting off
the acella I took the Acela from New
York to Washington DC
and I got off the train like everybody
else and I was walking down the platform
like everyone else and I walked past
General nordie Schwartz who used to be
the chief of staff of the United States
Air Force the head of the Air Force and
here I did you see a guy in a suit
schlepping his own suitcase down the
platform just like me and just a couple
months ago he was flying on private jets
and he had an Entourage and other people
carried his luggage but he no longer
held the position and so now he got to
drag his own suitcase and never did it
sort of remind me more that none of us
deserve the perks that we get we all
deserve a styrofoam cup
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to get
some more incredible Simon static
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there so there's another guy who does
what I do he's extremely well respected
he does extremely good work I hate him
he's always been very nice to me when
I've seen him professionally just I have
an irrational hatred of them and
whenever his name comes up I like it
drives me nuts like people bring it like
where we hired him